encore cette paix des lots ou ceux qui
s'essaient à rozelay découvre c'est
terminé allez maintenant on va résoudre
tt lit je veux savoir qui est peiné
leurs peines et leurs peines et leurs
pénélope simons leiter les sétois
pénélope un nom d'onex terre on est à la
recherche de pénélope est ce que vous
savez qui c'est non je n'ai pas aimé la
pérouse à la rigueur je connais oui 6
non seulement tu as non pas du tout ces
tumeurs ou y pour moi
tiens justement de savoir une photo vous
l'avez déjà vu ce monsieur là autour
d'un café
on a déjà dû la croiser dans le bâtiment
droit lettres à la poitrine mais de
temps en temps un peu partie assez
pénible elle s'appelle comme ça dépend
et alors vous la trouvez comment elle
est très très alléchant alors j'ai dit
ouais elle est mignonne exposé avec nous
en cours sur la table même parfois sur
le bureau des proches
en plus elle est hyper câline ouais
j'avoue c'est moi pénélope
ça fait trois ans que j'habite ici avec
les ânes c'est vrai que vu du genre
capricieuse je suis une vraie tigresse
[Musique]
mon terrain de jeu bah c'est le bâtiment
droit lettres et dormir dans les bureaux
les salles de classe ça c'est entre
j'adore les deux caresse des étudiants
et surtout leur sandwich à la beauté
puis irrésistible fait tourner la tête
de tous ceux que je croise les réseaux
sociaux ça c'est mon dada homeland on
tweet on snap n'ai qu'une chose à dire
beyoncé et les 2 autres millions de gens
en france n'ont qu'à bien se tenir
[Musique]